le président bouteflika nous a accordé
un entretien que nous avons enregistrées
dans le courant de cet après-midi en
duplex d'alger du palais présidentiel
première question monsieur bouteflika
elle concerne son choix d'user du
référendum pour obtenir un assentiment
populaire dans ses décisions marquant
son souhait d'une concorde nationale
monsieur de bouteflika il n'y a aucune
réticence au niveau de l'armée
mais j'ai besoin du soutien populaire
pour avancer il est tout à fait clair
que nous sommes dans une expérience
démocratique nous a fait naissante et
que les voix ne sont pas unanimes pour
telle ou telle autre démarche qui dit
démocratie dix principes de gouvernement
avec la majorité
il est tout à fait clair que une telle
[Musique]
mesure de par sa dimension et son
caractère historique me paraissent me
paraît en tout cas appelé un suffrage
populaire
une jeune je dois avoir l'aval populaire
pour prendre les décisions adéquates
je considère que chaque goutte
algérienne de sang à son pays et il est
tout à fait clair que je ferai tout ce
qui est en mon pouvoir de faire pour
arrêter cette tragédie pour faire la
paix monsieur le président il faut ils
vont négocier avec son adversaire
est ce que vous êtes prêt à engager des
discussions des entretiens avec des
représentants du gia par exemple
monsieur je ne la république négocie
avec personne la république est là à
partir d'une constitution à partir
d'institutions à partir de lois
républicaines qui essaie d'offrir des
solutions à ceux qui pour une raison ou
une autre et à avoir des raisons
objectives aux demeures se sont laissés
entraîner vers un phénomène d'expression
par la violence je crois avoir ouvert le
champ ou si vaste que je peux le faire
dans le cadre de mes attributions en
tant que magistrat numéro un du pays
pour permettre aussi bien aux uns et aux
autres de rejoindre le bercail sans
tarder la face alors concernant la
politique que vous entendez menés en
algérie vous avez annoncé une lutte
contre la corruption
ça veut dire quoi concrètement à mon
cher ami je voudrais vous dire une chose
c'est que je trouve une situation où il
ya très peu de choses qui ne sont pas
tout à fait courant peut alors pas quoi
commencer je pense que
sur le plan national il ya un certain
nombre de mesures qui me paraissent
inévitables c'est la mort dans l'âme que
je le fais mais je le ferai mais je
militerai sur le plan international pour
une convention internationale de lutte
contre la corruption dans le monde
c'est un fléau absolument terrible et
qui ne permettra jamais aux pays du
tiers-monde de décoller si cette
situation devait continuer la population
algérienne est très jeunes y ait
beaucoup de jeunes femmes notamment
beaucoup d'entre elles s'inquiètent du
code de la famille du statut de la femme
avez vous l'intention de réformer ce
code voire de l'abroger
tout ce qui est en mon pouvoir de faire
je le ferai je ne porterai jamais jamais
jamais un verset coranique raconte j'ai
la conviction profonde que le problème
n'est pas au niveau de la fois où des
versets coraniques
le problème est au niveau de la
calcification de certains esprits et
principalement de d'une population
algérienne qui n'a pas compris que les
52% de la population
c'est des femmes c'est une démarche
pédagogique qui demandera un peu de
temps je la ferai c'est un pari qui ne
fait pas peur
de toutes les façons je n'aurai pas peur
ces comptes de pouce on sait déjà une
majorité pour gouverner un pays
alors vous avez des liens personnels je
crois très anciens avec le président
chirac
qu'est ce que vous attendez directement
de lui vous avez montré un petit
agacement juste après votre élection en
disant que les les français devait un
peu se mêler de leurs affaires mais
qu'ils devaient montrer très directement
le rattachement avec l'algérie non je
n'ai pas montré d'agacement je suis là
comme le président chirac est chargé de
défendre les intérêts supérieurs de son
pays de la france et c'est son droit et
son devoir je suis là aussi pour
défendre les intérêts supérieurs de mon
pays et c'est aussi l'endroit est mon
devoir
si je le fais à ma manière je ne suis ni
content ni agacé je le fais à ma manière
c'est simplement une question de style
de formulation peut être que la langue
française n'étant pas ma langue
maternelle je la manipule de façon
suffisamment compréhensibles pour mes
interlocuteurs mais je dis très
sincèrement ce que je pense du fond du
coeur avec un coeur immense immense
immense et qui peut contenir toute la
france il comptait bien entendu mon ami
le président chirac payant de la culée
française je remercie monsieur le
président nous avons accordé cet
entretien merci beaucoup